[Music]
hello and welcome to safety Ridge on
Sunday after months or years of a
political roller coaster where you can't
focus on anything apart from the fact
you're being held upside down every five
minutes there's one thing that suffered
our focus on policy well on the show
today we want to begin to correct that
the parties are beginning to come up
with a policy platform for the next
election the health secretary with his
plan for the NHS Workforce for instance
and today Labor is launching their plan
for teachers we'll talk about what the
two parties want to talk about but also
what they don't what's a fair pay rise
for workers in a time of inflation
coming up on the show today in just a
moment we will hear from the house
secretary that is Steve Barkley and for
labor will speak to the party's Shadow
education secretary Bridget Phillipson
with more teaching strikes in the next
few weeks standing even bigger row about
wider public sector pay on the horizon
we'll talk to the General Secretary of
the biggest education Union that is Dr
Mo busted of the Neu
the green business Mandel Vince is a big
donor to the labor party he also funds
the protest group just stop oil so we'll
talk to him on the program too
plus we'll have a really fascinating
insight into life in number 10 under the
last four Prime Ministers and the
current one by the man who captured them
all on film Danning Street photographer
Andrew Parsons
[Music]
foreign
well this week we've got the very
long-awaited Workforce plan for the NHS
it's meant to deal with the long-term
Staffing crisis but with consultants and
Junior doctors on strike in the coming
weeks and another playground on the
horizon it's the short-term problems in
the Health Service that remain a big
problem for the government a little
earlier I spoke to the health secretary
Steve Buckley
there's been another night of violence
in Paris are you monitoring the
situation closely well it's something
that the foreign and Commonwealth office
will be monitoring very closely they
keep regular updates on their website
and what I would say to anyone concerned
about it who's thinking of traveling to
France to keep an eye on the foreign
office website there'll be regular
updates there and that will keep people
informed and there was one other story
in the newspapers today that I wanted to
ask you about before talk about the NHS
and the Sunday Telegraph were reporting
that overhead cables and pylons are
going to be fast tracked through the
planning system is that true well
there's a balance to be stroke we don't
think the approach on energy is to add
28 billion to our national debt that is
the proposal okay yeah yeah
find out what you're going to do what we
need to do is look at how we speed up
infrastructure and how we do so in a
smart way that reduces cost but balances
that with the voice of residence so it's
important we take on board local
concerns we respond to Residents we have
the right
of consultation but there are smarter
ways of speeding up infrastructure and
we should be looking at that because
that's a way of bringing costs down
whilst also getting the balance right in
terms of listening to local people and
also it sounds like if the UK is going
to deliver on the net zero pledge that's
going to be more wind power it's going
to be more electric cars I mean that's
pressure on the National Grid you've got
to do something well we made huge
progress so far there's been a 500
increase in renewable energy since 2010
we're the second uh best in Europe for
that so shoes progress has been made but
at the same time we should be looking at
how do we bring costs down rather than
adding debt making things more expensive
as labor want to do we want to bring the
cost of these schemes down and look at
how we work in a smarter one so fast
tracking through planning sounds like
it's going to happen well it's looking
at for example of a huge amount of money
that's often spent on Consultants
endless reports things that take a long
time often them for the same decision to
be reached so it's about how do we get
the decision right how do we listen to
local people that is hugely imp
but doing so in a balanced way and I
think often a lot of money is going on
Consultants writing reports taking them
a long period of time we think we can
work smarter than that and bring the
cost down okay now this week you launch
your NHS Workforce plan so you'll plan
to train and keep more staff in the NHS
you've already done interviews on it so
I don't want to spend too long dwelling
on the details but there's one question
I haven't really seen anyone ask you 2.4
billion pounds over five years where's
that money coming from well it's through
uh cross government through the treasury
that was part of the discussions we had
and it signaled the Prime Minister and
the Chancellor's personal support what
is this what does that mean then is it
more money to your department or you can
have to find it from NHS existing
budgets or is it borrowing what was it
coming from so this is additional money
it will be announced as a former Chief
secretary will be announced in the usual
way through fiscal events it ramps up
because obviously one of the features of
the workforce plan and it is the biggest
ever expansion in Workforce training in
the NHS it's a hugely historic moment as
we celebrate the 75th anniversary of the
NHS the Fantastic achievements of the
NHS it's a major commitment from the
government and it reflects the the prime
minister's personal commitment to the
NHS coming from an NHS found both his
parents worked in the NHS and the
chancellor has long called for a
long-term Workforce plan so reflects
their support it's 2.4 billion of
additional funding that will be
announced by the chancellor in the usual
way at the next fiscal event there's
additional funding to the department so
I haven't heard any you know tax Rises
or spending cuts so I'm assuming this
sounds like it might be extra borrowing
100 of GDP that's the current level of
debt interest rates Rising so the cost
of service in government debt is going
up is that really responsible well it
scales up Sophie so first year obviously
you and have one year of people being
trained in the second year that doubles
the policy of 2.4 billion without saying
how that money was coming from you would
be after them like a rocket it scales up
you've got to see that in terms of the
way that doubling on medical
undergraduates works is obviously that
is cumulative because the second you've
got double the number the third year
triple so that scales up over time but
also it helps in terms of the cost of
agency the cost of bank and other
support so it's important to our
retention in the NHS if we have more NHS
staff staying that is a cost-effective
approach so what the plan is about is
training more yes but also how do we
have better retention and also how do we
deliver that training in more efficient
ways through reform so there's three
elements to the plan not just the
increase in numbers but also the work on
training and reform the one thing that
could also help the NHS recruit and
retained staff is better pay and the
independent pay of your bodies will soon
publish their recommendations about the
uplift that health workers should get
will you stick by what they recommend
well we'll take those decisions on a
cross-government basis I'm very pleased
we've now reached agreement with the
largest group within the NHS excuse me
which is the agenda for change uh
Workforce that's 1.3 million people
within the NHS where the government and
the NHS staff Council has reached
agreement that means those staff will
get the pay-up lifts in their pay
packets this month so that's shows the
progress that we are making in terms of
The Wider prb that is something that is
discussed cross-government it's not just
an issue within Health it also affects
for example teachers and the education
unions in fact other departments in
government so we'll have those
discussions on a cross government basis
but it's hugely positive that we have
reached agreement with the largest of
the health bodies the 1.3 million
covered by agenda for change it's weird
that you won't say that you'll stick to
the pay review recommendations because
this is what you said about them last
year and when you're talking about pay
there and you tweeted to say we have an
independent pay review body which the
unions campaign to set up and we will
continue to defer to that process to
ensure decisions balance the needs of
staff and The Wider economy so you'll
defer to the pay of your body when you
like what they say but you reserve the
right to ignore them when you don't I
think when I was on the show previously
you criticized me for adhering to the
full pay-per-view body because there was
a pressure to go further there was
questions in terms of because of the
change in inflation you were saying we
shouldn't just stick to the full paper
you already we should actually go
further and indeed the government I'm
putting the differences forward so as
you would expect me to do well I'm just
trying to work out why your position
you're the health secretary right you're
the one who has actually influence I'm
just a lowly TV reporter I've got no say
over at what pay all these people get
why do you say that you should defer to
the pay review process when you like
what they say and not when you don't
well the point we discussed when this
was raised last time and you bring the
quote up from last time which is why I'm
making the point was we should also look
at the wider economic circumstance and
that was the point that you were raising
with me you know last time Sophie and
that's why you say here instead you
should balance the needs of staff and
The Wider economy now you're saying
actually we just need to look at the
wider economy not the needs of stuff
we need to do that we need to do both
and that's exactly what we have done
with the agenda for change which is why
not only did we apply the full
pay-per-view body recommendations we
actually went further in terms of a lump
sum first time because we hugely
recognize the pressure that NHS staff
have been under from the pandemic I know
the population advances in medicine
enabling more to be done we both adopted
the full pay review body but we actually
went further last time of course we need
to look at the wider pressures in terms
of inflation our commitment to halving
inflation growing the economy reducing
debt as well as cutting waiting times
and stopping the boat so we need to look
at these things in the round that's what
we did last time which is why we made
adjustments of course we'll take a
similar approach this time they're
expected to recommend a six percent rise
for NHS staff would that be acceptable
to you well as I say these will be
discussions that I have on behalf of the
health Workforce with the Prime Minister
the chancellor that the education
secretary will have on behalf of
teachers and other ministers will have
across government so we will have those
and we'll make announcements in due
course
um you were early
it's great that you have an appointment
with some people who work for NHS and
but of course Junior doctors is
outstanding they're planning their
longest ever strike later this month
Thursday the 13th to Tuesday the 18th of
July will that put lines at risk well
it's hugely concerning and it's hugely
grateful to those within the NHS who
have stepped up when we've had past
Junior doctor strikes who come in often
change their holiday plans to provide uh
cover the junior adopters are continuing
to demand a 35 pay rise I don't think
that is Affordable in the context of the
inflation is that true they say that
they want to get around the table and
actually thrash something out but you
don't want to talk to them do you well
we have and we had three weeks of talks
not only that they asked to bring an
intermediary and a very senior respected
NHS leader Kathy McLean who had played a
pivotal role in a previous dispute
between sus doctors and the department
the department agreed to bring it in and
out intermediary but notwithstanding
Kathy's excellent work the discussions
that we had with the junior doctors to
date they have refused to move from a 35
demand where they talk of a additional
year using 2024-25 actually they demand
a 49 increase because of that additional
year so I don't think that in the
context of The Wider economy the need to
get inflation down that is a fair demand
of course both sides need to move we are
willing to do so in government we have
accepted the use of the intermediary
that the BMA why don't you get around
the table with them now it seems a bit
arrogant doesn't it if you won't even
talk to them now or being consistent not
just in health but in all departments
that if people suspend the strikes then
we can get around the table have talks
on the moon the junior doctors have
walked away from the tours we were in
the middle of discussions with them
there were a range of other factors that
they have raised with me in terms of
annual leave that is often canceled at
short notice rotors that have changed
some of the well-being issues around uh
circumstances in hospital so we're happy
to discuss those we were in the middle
of discussing some of those wider
non-pay issues is the junior doctors
suddenly who walked away from the
discussions and called a further strike
now whenever she's your next five
pledges was to cut NHS waiting times
how's that going oh well we're making
progress on our longest weights that's
what the plan uh committed to we
virtually eliminated the two-year
weights last summer we committed to
reduce the 18-month weights we cleared
over 90 percent of those and if you can
trust our performance with labor run uh
the NHS in Wales we're making much more
progress so we've got a population 18
times the size of the NHS in Wales if
you've just let me finish the population
in England is 18 times the size of that
in Wales we virtually eliminated our
two-year weights in the summer we got
our 18-month weights to down below 12
000 yet in Wales that was 30 000 for two
year weight and around 70 000 for 18
month weight so we're making much more
progress than we see in labor and
memorials and yet Kirsten Thomas says
that's the blueprint for a labor
government if you forgive me for coming
in
um thank you very much and the number of
people waiting for routine treatment has
risen from 7.2 million to 7.4 million I
mean most people would say that does not
look like progress most people who are
experiencing what's going on in the NHS
would not say that looks like progress
if you look at the plan that was set out
in 2022 by NHS England it always
anticipated that the bounce back from
the pandemic would mean that in terms of
the overall size of the list it may
continue to grow everything
coming down in March of next year now
what we're doing is fast tracking things
like our diagnostic Centers we've got
108 open uh now we're going to have 160
open shortly that's delivered 4 million
additional tests and scans we've got
more treatment being capacity being
rolled out 43 new and expanded surgical
hubs so we're boosting our treatment
that takes time to come on stream we're
making progress we're cutting the
longest weight okay and we're fast
tracking the capacity to bring the
overall size of the waiting list out I
just want to be honest you know looking
at the five pledgers that which is
unique made that he said he wanted to be
judged on and it seems like you guys are
on pretty Shaky Ground you know half
inflation stop the boats cut debt when
the Prime Minister announced them six
months ago he said simply no tricks no
ambiguity we're either delivering for
you or we're not what happens if you're
not well the Prime Minister was clear
these were tough targets that he set
himself and rightly so well most people
thought they were easy that they were
low bars well you can now see that there
were tough targets that were set and it
was right that we did so enough to take
waiting list the plan is working we
cleared the longest weights the two year
weights we cleared we cleared the
longest way it's what the plan set out
was the target the longest weights we
cleared the two-year weights last summer
we cleared over 90 of the 18-month
weights we're now focused on the 65 week
weeks that's the next element of the
plan and we're massively accelerating
the world out of our diagnostic Centers
overall Quantum down three of the five
pledges around the economy but debt is
100 percent of GDP the economy grew by
0.2 percent in April inflation is far
higher than expected you know what
happens when the guy who says he's the
one to fix the economy doesn't actually
fix the economy well you see that
because we've had two 100 Year events of
course there's been huge pressures and
these are not alone to the economy in
England
issues for our economy you will
acknowledge that so you're a smart guy
you know that well we're growing the
economy we recognize recognized at that
reasonably the progress that has been
made but of course we've had two one in
100 Year events those have had an impact
but if you look at the progress we're
making in-house the rolling out of
national lung cancer screening this week
now I guess you know the question was
what happens if the guy who says he
fixes his economy doesn't fix the
economy and I think I think really we
know people will start turning away from
the conservative party a poll in the
Sunday Telegraph by opinion finds your
own course for the biggest by-election
defeat in British history mid
bedfordshire when Nadine Dorsey C and
before you say it's just one poll I
think a look at our Sky News poll
tracker which shows unsurprisingly
perhaps you know the conservatives are
still well behind labor not much sign of
that improving at all
at what point do you start to panic well
we recognize it's tough because we've
had a pandemic we've had a war in Europe
that's had a big impact in terms of
inflation in cost of living but look at
what labor is coming for when nothing in
terms of helping on inflation they want
to add 28 billion to our debt that will
make the problem whereas if you look at
stopping the small boats there's no Pro
uh proposal from labor to do so
absolutely silence on that if you look
at our biggest ever expansion of the
workforce in the NHS this week that by
2.4 billion pounds labor has no
proposals on reform in their equivalent
plan it was completely silent on the
innovations that we're bringing forward
and what we're doing is getting on in
innovating coming out of the pandemic if
I take the example of lung cancer in our
most deprived communities previously
four in five patients were diagnosed
late we've turned that on its head it's
now through our Pilots three and four
that are diagnosed early if you look at
the investment we'll make taking in
research to get the latest Innovations
into the NHS 96 million pounds we
announced on Tuesday for 93 different
institutions if you look at the work of
mental health often that's been an area
that's been neglected significant
additional funds 2.3 billion more this
year than four years ago so a huge
amount of innovation and work is going
on we will recognize there's much more
to do just finally rumors of a reshuffle
after the by-elections next month and I
just want to read you a quote in the
times if I may I think you might know
which is coming most of the cabinet the
time says is expected to emerge
unscathed although there continues to be
speculation about the futures of Steve
Barkley the health secretary and Therese
Coffey the environment secretary
don't worry of course it's always for
the prime minister to pick the the
cabinet and his team and I've worked for
three prime ministers and you can see
the progress we're making as I say if I
just take this week the lung cancer
National screening the run out of
research the progress on mental health
and the workforce plan and that's what
I'm focused on all right not polishing
up that CV just yet then well focused on
delivery and that's what we do okay
thank you very much
well that was the house secretary at
Steve Barkley now we were just talking
about the Staffing and the strike crisis
and health fair but of course things
aren't much better in the education
sector either where more strikes are due
and there's no resolution in sight
meanwhile absence rates from schools
still worryingly high after the pandemic
so what would labor do well this is my
interview with the party's Shadow
education secretary Bridget Phillipson
thank you very much for being on the
program and we know that there are
issues recruiting and retaining teachers
in our schools that one in five quit in
the first two years so what's your plan
to tackle that
this is a massive problem especially
because we know that teacher equality is
the most important factor in driving of
outcomes for children and young people
where it comes to what happens within
school that's why I'm setting out
Labor's plans to make sure that we are
supporting people into teaching we do
face this real crisis but more
importantly that we keep them there I
think the best recruitment strategy is a
really strong retention strategy so
we'll introduce
new payments for early career teachers
when they complete their training will
reform the very complicated landscape
that exists at the moment with some of
those wider payments but also labor will
insist that all new teachers coming into
teaching will have to have qualified
teacher status I'll be working towards
it for me this is about sending a really
important signal that we value and
respect the work of our teachers we know
it's an incredibly skilled job and I
want to reset that relationship between
government and the profession so it's a
one-off payments uh just how much is it
again so it'll be in total 15 million
pounds paid for by ending the tax breaks
on private schools so two two thousand
four hundred pounds for the individual
teacher right
um I understand you know the issues that
you have in trying to keep people in the
profession but it's experienced in
senior teachers who've experienced the
biggest fall in real terms pay down 13
from 2010 according to the ifs so would
you give them a pay rise it's a
complicated picture in terms of why
people are leaving I don't think there's
one particular measure that will address
everything but where it comes to what
I've set out around changes on workload
on ofsted on better support within our
schools around mental health there are a
lot of the big challenges that school
leaders and more experienced staff in
particularly with me my question was
will you give experienced teachers a pay
rise under the last Labor government
experience teaches all teachers saw
sustained pay risers they haven't seen
them 13 years ago they're asking what
you do now would you give them a pay
rise now well I think if you compare and
contrast our record from last time
around with the record of the
conservatives which is a 13 real terms
pay cut for teachers on average over the
course of the last decade but the
economy isn't a part of State the
conservatives crashed the economy they
were incredibly reckless in the approach
that they took we're committed to being
serious about the negotiations that we
would have in getting to a better
position all teachers I believe deserve
a fair fair kind of support Fair pay for
the work they do but also to be
recognized for their incredible
professionalism and the pair everybody
is recommended that teachers get a 6.5
pay rise next year so would a labor
government accept that well that's what
we understand to be the case but the
government won't publish the independent
peer review bodies report I want to see
it I think teachers deserve to see it
school leaders who are trying to plan
their budgets for September
urgently need of course you want to see
it everyone wants to see it I want to
see it the viewers want to say it would
you accept a 6.5 pay rise for teachers
what we're speculating on what we think
it might be okay well my question is
except a 6.5 pay rise I would say that
as the starting point for negotiation we
can't get anywhere unless we're prepared
to negotiate we I understand that I
understand it what does that mean
they're everything point for negotiation
does that mean you would want to give
them more than 6.5 percent does that
mean you want to I just don't understand
what does that mean as I understand it
there have been no serious negotiations
led by the Secretary of State since
April so it's little wonder that we're
facing further strike action this week
because she won't talk to them she won't
publish the report and she want to speak
to the teaching unions I would be
talking to them trying to find a way
through it resolving issues around pay
resolving issues around workload and
what I'm setting out this week is a
really ambitious plan for how we respect
and appreciate teachers for what they're
doing give them better ongoing
professional development and more
support for early career teachers with
that new retention payment all paid for
by ending the tax breaks on private
schools
so would I I'm sorry that I keep feel
like you probably feel like I just keep
going on about this but the reason is
because I don't really understand the
answer that you're giving me would labor
accept a 6.5 pay raise for teachers well
I want to see the report we all want to
see the report
I'm just asking a straight question 6.5
for teachers I'm not going to come on
this program and commit to a figure I
wouldn't expect the Secretary of State
to do that either that is what will
happen during the course of a
negotiation where you will arrive at a
position that everyone can live with so
I wouldn't expect the Secretary of State
to be committing to that number what I
do expect the Secretary of State to be
doing I think what any sensible and
credible government would be doing would
be trying to find a way through the
impasse publishing the report committing
to talks getting serious about it not
constantly belittling teachers picking
fights in newspapers and focusing on
peripheral narrow issues the most
important thing that parents want to
know right now is is the teacher in
front of my child's class qualified are
they properly supported for what they're
doing and can we get these strikes to
come to an end in principle should the
government accept the pay review
recommendations well they've said that
they will previously so we'll wait and
see what happens we take that seriously
difficult I'm asking you know in
principle should a government accept the
pay review recommendation that is
normally what happens yes that is
normally what takes place
um what we're seeing at the moment is
far from the normal kind of process so
when you've got a government that has
received these reports won't publish the
report I think it's incredibly
disrespectful we're almost at the end of
the summer term School leaders want to
plan on that basis they don't know what
their budgets are going to be we need a
different kind of relationship it has to
involve respecting teachers for what
they're doing we're not always going to
agree with them about how much you've
given well they're not pay risers if I
was Secretary of State I would
absolutely be straight about that but
we're not in government at the moment
when we are in government if we win the
trust of the British people they will
have an honest straightforward
relationship with me we won't always
agree but I'll be around that table
seeking to work it out and get to a
better position that is what our
children deserve not this ridiculous
politicking that we see from the Tories
teachers are striking for two more days
next week disruptive for pupils
disruptive of course for parents as well
do you support The Strokes it is
incredibly disruptive I don't want the
strikes to happen most of the teachers
I've spoken to recently when visiting
schools tell me the last thing they ever
imagined when they became a teacher was
going out on strike and in some cases
this is the first time in their career
that very experienced teachers are
taking strike action but there is still
time for the Secretary of State to
commit to talks to publish the report
and then hopefully those strikes could
be averted and I want to talk to you a
little bit on Child Care a big big issue
for so many people of course what's
Labor's offer on Child Care uh we'll be
setting up more later this week as part
of the mission that I'll be launching
with Kia around the importance of making
sure all of our children get a great
start in life my position is that I want
to deliver a reformed and modern child
care system from the end of Parental
leave to the end of primary school the
first step I've set out around that is
breakfast clubs for every Primary School
child in England that would make a
massive difference during the cost of
living crisis for parents but also for
children all of the evidence is really
clear that you get better outcomes for
children when you have that started to
the day in an interview at the Sunday
Times in January you said that the scale
and ambition of your child care reforms
will be like the creation of the NHS and
they reported it saying that you wanted
to guarantee child care for all parents
of children aged 9 months to 11 years
are you going to do that for all her
children and parents or are you going to
means test it I've got to make sure that
there are child care places available
right across our country which is not
the situation at the moment but we have
provided it's a really and just trying
to find out what the policy is if that's
okay are you going to guarantee child
care for all parents and children aged
in almost 11 years or you're going to
mean to test that what I was talking
about was the permanent shift that we
need to see where we treat earlier as
education and child care as an integral
part of our education system that is the
permanent shift that I want to see on a
scale with the NHS because what we have
in this country is early as education
somewhere over here not integral to the
education system that is very different
from most of the European countries
alongside that making sure that when
we're putting more money into the system
the government did did respond to what
the pressure that we've been applying
and put more money into the system at
the budget that gives us a better
baseline from which to build a better
system that will support parents and
actually a real focus on quality of the
provision because I want to make sure
that particularly our most Advantage
children get a really good start in life
at the moment lots of those children are
not accessing earlier's education you
see I know how passionate you are about
child care and you know about the impact
it has on children or mothers as well
perhaps from your own experience I'm
just trying to work out
you know what happened to these reforms
did Rachel Reeves get on the phone and
say look you've got to scale this back
we can't fool this what actually
happened nothing has you know nothing
has happened in that in that way I'm
absolutely determined to deliver early
as education and child care reform it is
a major priority for me it will be a big
priority for the next Labor government
and I know what it is for Rachel too she
spoken about the importance quite
rightly of the economic impact of women
moving out of work or cutting back on
their hours because Child Care isn't
there but alongside that I want to see a
real focus on making sure that all of
our children get a really really great
start in life but we have to be aware of
every every part of what we've set out
so far has been fully funded and fully
costed and that will be continued to be
our position but we have we will if the
net if we do happen to form the next
Labor government if we're so fortunate
that the people British people trust us
we will face an incredibly difficult
fiscal inheritance because the
conservatives have trashed the economy
and that will present us with some
really tough choices there's one other
story that you you want to get your
reaction to um Catherine bubble Singh
who is the head teacher of the very high
achieving School Michaela in Brent in
London She's accused Your Shadow cabinet
colleague Jess Phillips of racism after
a bit of a Twitter route and she's
written to kirst armor to say her
behavior is a clear example of
unconscious bias I mean that she hates
me despite not knowing me because she
subscribes to the idea that black and
Asian individuals in public life owe a
duty to voice opinions that match with a
left-wing view of the world or they are
worthy of her contempt
your reaction to this
my reaction to anyone who feels unhappy
about the conduct of a labor MP is that
they should complain through our
processes and then that the matter can
be looked into and as members of
parliament we're also subject to a code
of conduct in Parliament as well and
there are processes in place for people
who are unhappy with an MPS Behavior to
report it in that way I would suggest
that to any individual that's unhappy
about the conduct of a member of
parliament so she thinks you think it's
right for her to put in an official
Complaint about this I think anyone who
is unhappy about the conduct of an MP in
any way
um should should make their concerns
known and then they can be properly
considered do you think Jess Phillips is
racist that's no I don't
um but I think it's important that if
people have concerns if they're unhappy
about the conduct as a member of
Parliament that can be investigated as
part of that process
and just sort of The Wider Point as well
and it feels like Catherine Bible sing
feels that she is being I guess
penalized or used as a bit of a
lightning rod because she's not doesn't
have a left-wing view of the world and
that many people in the teaching
profession and Leadership roles in
teaching I guess she would say do do you
think there's any truth in that when I
visit schools the length and breadth of
the country what I find are dedicated to
people who are focused on making sure
children get a great start in life very
rarely will the conversation drift into
into politics what people come into
teaching to do and what people uh you
know when they become School leaders are
focused on as well is delivering really
high quality educations and that's
that's as it should be would you like to
visit the school that she runs I love I
visit schools everywhere I'm always open
to invitations to visit schools right
across the country it's the best part of
the job okay thank you very much thank
you
uh well that was Bridget Phillipson for
labor you're watching safety Ridge on
Sunday this morning uh lots of policy
discussion there with both labor and the
conservatives and still to come on the
program this morning it is this lady it
is a doctor married boosted from the
education Union the National Education
Union lots to talk to her about about
teachers pay about strikes and about
schools as well plus but later we're
going to hear from the green businessman
who funds just up oil and gives a lot of
money to labor too that is Dale Vince
plus we'll get some immediate reaction
from our Deputy political editor Sam
coats who's watching all of our
interviews we'll speak to Sam on the
show a little bit later for his take
[Music]
well the issue of public sector pay is
clearly still high on the agenda for the
government and there is talk that Rishi
sunak could reject the recommendations
or the pay review bodies for this year's
settlement as we've been hearing this
morning that could make matters worse in
both health and education well teachers
are going on strike again later this
month we can now speak to the General
Secretary of the biggest Union the Neu
and that is Dr Mary balstead thank you
very much for being on the program this
morning I want to talk about strikes um
but just before I do we've got this new
labor announcement of a retention
payment for 2400 for two years for
teachers do you think that's a good
policy
I think that's a good start yes um I
mean obviously and the teachers union
leader so any extra money for teachers
is a good idea the problem with
bursaries which is the money that
training teachers get while they're
training is that that doesn't there's no
requirement for them to stay in the
profession so a two-year incentive is a
good idea it's a start of course we
would want labor to go much further we
want better salaries for the experienced
teachers as well I mean there is a this
the government at the moment is sort of
money moving money towards paying new
teachers more
but the problem we have also is
experienced teachers are leaving the
profession in droves forty thousand
experienced teachers left the profession
last year that's nine percent of uh
teachers all the teachers eight percent
of head teachers left last year is
experience that we're missing in the
profession and so yes we need to pay
beginning teachers more but we need to
also significantly raise salaries for
all teachers I did it specifically ask
about pay for experienced teachers um
and didn't get anything from Bridget
Phillips and she also didn't say that
they would commit to the recommendation
of the pay review body for a 6.5 rise
for teachers is that concerning you well
she said was watching outside she said
it would be a starting point and we hope
that what labor mean by that is yes that
is the starting point and they would
accept it but don't you think she meant
the opposite that it was a starting
point for a teaching side and then I
didn't see the interview I would be
surprised if that was the case but the
issue is we're not negotiating with
labor I can't really speculate on what
labor would do because at the moment our
dispute is with the current government
the conservative government who have
Rishi sunak and Jeremy Hunt and Jillian
Keegan have over the course of the last
two months in Parliament proudly
proclaimed that they are leaving the
they are now leading up to the
independent pay review body we've had
Rishi sunak in prime minister's
questions saying we've always
implemented the peer review body now we
understand that the pay review body has
understood that the crisis in teacher
supplies now so bad that they are going
they've gone beyond the government what
the government says that they want to
pay teachers and recommended six and a
half percent
and so as they've exercised their
independence which the government has
been lauding for months now the
government is saying something different
which is we'll consider it in the round
now actually they could have said that
during the past few months they could
have said we're leaving it to the
independent pay review body and we will
get their recommendations we'll consider
them that is not the impression that
they've given at all is it because
in the last few weeks it's become clear
that the economic situation is worse
than most people are expecting and the
government of the bank of England for
example Andrew Bailey telling Ed Conway
from Sky a couple of weeks ago that the
UK cannot continue to have the current
level of wage Rises because they're
inflationary is that do you think do you
have any sympathy with that argument no
I have no sympathy with that argument at
all
um the oecd reported last week that it
is private sector profits which are
driving inflation uh not partly not
entirely the majority the part of the
increase is private sector profits but I
think it is acknowledged by the bank of
England and others that pay comes into
it well public sector pay
doesn't produce a way a price hike at
the points of use consumers if they're
using State education don't pay per
lesson uh consumers don't if they're
using the National Health Service pay
per time they go it doesn't feed into
cost price rises in the same way that
you could argue excessive pay rises in
the private sector although we haven't
seen those feeds into the prices people
pay and the consequences of not paying
public sector workers is that they are
leaving public service and the services
which they provide are collapsing you
have to invest there's no evidence that
public sector pay feeds into inflation
that's just become an argument which the
government is now using in another
attempt well that's what demands say as
well right well just the government of
England governor on half a million a
year can say he he's quite at Liberty to
say that
um teachers who earn on average less
than 40 000 pounds a year shouldn't get
a pay rise I'm not going to take lessons
from him now the Neu is trunking again
uh Fifth and 7th of July you've already
had multiple days of strikes this year
how long are you prepared to keep
striking full
well we don't want to go on strike and
what I want to do on this program is
apologize to parents and you know to say
that the last thing that teachers want
to do is lose two more days wages
they're not being paid enough as it is
and to disrupt their children's
education any further but you know we
are at a crisis Point I've given you the
number of teachers leaving the
profession
that's bad enough they're leaving
this year the government is going to
miss its secondary training place
numbers by 50 over 50 percent
we have a million children being taught
in classes of over 30. we have the
highest class sizes amongst the highest
in the developed World alongside Brazil
Colombia and Mexico our class sizes we
have children routinely being taught by
teachers who are not teaching in the
subject area that they even have a an
a-level link and you have a
in our schools there is a crisis every
day in our schools and
estate for education for months when
you're in dispute how else are we meant
to how else are my members else meant to
say we can't carry on like this anymore
are children still getting a good
education
the the children are getting the very
best education that teachers can give
them teachers work the most unpaid
overtime of any profession working weeks
of 55 000 over but how much better could
we do if education was funded properly
and if there were enough teachers and
head teachers to teach and Lead schools
do just before I've got you there's one
other story that I would like to get
your view on it's this round between
Catherine bevelsting who is a head
teacher of a school in London and Jess
Phillips who She's accused of racism she
said she subscribes to the idea that
black and Asian individuals in public
life owe a duty to voice opinions that
match with the left wing view of the
world now this is a genuine question
um I just think that some of our viewers
would say that they have an impression
that teaching unions are of the left and
that there's a lot of people in teaching
who are of the left do you think there
is an acceptance of teachers who have
views that are politically from the
right
I guess I do think I mean I I taught for
a long time in schools and you meet
teachers of every political persuasion
and none although I have to say that
politics isn't something that's
routinely discussed in sufferings it's
usually your lesson and what's happened
and things like that yes I think and I
think that teachers of the right have
had a very very strong influence on
government policy they're the ones which
are routinely brought in to be part of
the focus groups and discussion groups
and the advisory groups
um you know so yeah I mean my union
isn't politically Affiliated we go to
the late party the lib Dems the greens
we go we're the only Union that goes to
and has a stand at the conservative
party we try to engage with all parties
so yes I think there is an acceptance I
don't think there is any rather the
reverse in terms of government policy
that teaches with right-wing political
views have had a disproportionate
influence on government over the last 12
years and teachers are you know who are
Center ground or of the left who are
saying sensible things have just been
dismissed as the blob do you um have
sympathy for Catherine bubble singing
this route she's that she's having well
I actually wasn't aware of this round so
I'd need to okay I need to have a look I
don't want to um say anything uh
particularly because I'm not aware of
that but on a general point it's
certainly not the case that teachers
with right-wing Jews have been ignored
by this government sure thank you very
much but we're really good having the
studio this morning thank you well as
usual the tape will follow this program
just after 9 30. that's our chance to
analyze today's interviews talk through
some news lines with our Deputy
political editor uh Sam coats but we can
get a little take from Sam just now a
bit of a taster if you like on what
stood out to him this morning uh salmon
thing in particular that's caught your
eye
well it's quite refreshing Sophie for
the first time maybe since 2016 that the
words Boris and Johnson haven't been
mentioned by this point on the show and
there we go I've just got to jinx that
but when you overturn the rock that
labeled policy so you find some
incredibly odd things and you've done it
with health and education on the show
this morning and you you find
politicians essentially behaving in ways
that you wouldn't expect so you've got a
conservative party that's spending big
money billions of pounds for instance on
that NHS Workforce plan 2.4 billion
pounds and as you effectively got Steve
Barkley to admit in not so many words
that is coming from the treasury that is
coming from borrowing so big borrowing
by the Tory party in order to fund their
plans but many many challenges on public
services ahead on the labor party
um they won't accept the independent
body necessarily the pay review bodies
recommendation when it comes to teachers
and very little detail from the
secretary Shadow Secretary of State for
Education Bridget Phillipson just one
concrete plan uh across all of the
interview that she was able to talk
about that's breakfast clubs uh for
people for kids from nine months to 11
years nothing else was she willing to
commit maybe we'll get a bit more when
kirstalmer gives his speech on
opportunity later this week but it's
joined to Me overall Sophie neither
party doing anything like what they need
to do on policy when we're only a little
more than a year out from a general
election big big challenges a long way
to go
that's what's making policy it's quite
unpredictable at the moment in the face
of lots of problems certainly is Sam and
I definitely share that that Sam was
saying I wasn't sure if we weren't
getting more on the child care policy
because they're about to announce it oh
because there's something going on
behind the scenes that means that you're
thrushing it out more from Sam at 9 30.
Now scan uses Westminster accounts
project was a big step forward in
providing transparency around the
funding of our politics and the
businessman and green campaign in Del
Vince has donated 1.5 million pounds to
labor after the last 10 years nothing
wrong with that of course but there's
been more controversy giving he also
funds the campaign group just stop oil
now I sat down with delvin's earlier
this week
now I feel like there's been an awful
lot said about you one headline who is
delvin's the hippie turned Eco Tycoon
funding the green zealots so how would
you describe yourself
uh I'm definitely hippie or an xcp I
don't think I'm uh I'm a funder of
zealots or a zealot myself which I've
also been called I've been called many
many things actually and and I think you
know it I don't I don't give her much
attention I'm first and foremost an
environmentalist I care passionately
about the uh the unsustainability of the
world that we live in and I've spent the
last three decades of pioneering a
number of different approaches to the
green economy and energy in transport in
food in football in diamonds all kinds
of stuff to try and bring about a a
green Britain my all of my work all of
my focus on the creation of green
Britain
there's been a
um 1.5 million pounds to the labor party
over the last 10 years has revealed by
Sky News back in January and also of
course money to just stop oil
problem
for me no
for other people perhaps they're saying
I guess I guess what other other people
might say right is
look people don't just give hundreds of
thousands of pounds of their own money
for no reason what is the reason for you
giving the donations to who because I
mean I also give money to Greenpeace to
see Shepherd to a women's Refuge to
school breakfast clubs to food banks you
know the list goes on to the labor party
to the labor party uh the reason I do
that is because I want them to win the
next election and there's always a
funding gap between labor and the Tories
a very big funding Gap and I tried to do
what I can to close that Gap is it that
influence as well no
never and I'm always very clear with
them I don't want anything and that is
very clear with me there's nothing on
offer anyway
do you think that at the back of their
minds if you've taken 1.5 million pounds
that there may be an influence question
there
for them I don't think so I think the
question is really surfaced by the
right-wing media it was a couple of
weeks ago it's been going on for 10
years right funding of the labor party
but if you look at funding of the
conservative party you know that's a
completely different uh story there's a
lot of opaqueness right you won't find a
funder of the Tory party willing to come
and talk to you about how much they've
given or why they've given this so you
welcome the scrutiny then I've got no
problem with it I I don't mind it at all
I obviously I don't welcome the
implications that come with it there's
some kind of deal going on behind you
know closed doors that kind of stuff you
know the idea that my donations caused
Kia stama to come out with the Nazi
policy that he has when in fact he
announced that a year ago in um
doubles and uh and yet two weeks ago the
bright green person like oh there's you
know there's just one and a half million
over the last 10 years Kirsten's got
this new policy which wasn't new and um
you know tried to join those dots and
say there's something going on it's it's
not fun
um but uh you know it's how they roll
and uh and I don't mind I mean we've
actually seen like for example recently
said you know it does appear that those
Eco zealots are just up oil are writing
kirst Armor's energy policy not content
with disrupting our summer and cherished
sporting events they're essentially
leading us into an energy surrender
that's a prime minister's for you and I
think you said that was in it when he
was in Washington and you'd think he had
better things to do that's what I
thought anyway and there's nothing
original in that from Richie sunac he
has no mandate to drill in the North Sea
for oil and gas he actually has no
mandate at all from the British people
he should call an election
you talk to kiss dumber and miliband for
example about policy I've known Ed
miliband since he was lead with a labor
advisor for some time and we've talked
occasionally and I've talked to kiss
Norma twice and what did you say in
those conversations well the last one as
I told the the listeners of the today
program was a five minute phone call in
which he thanked me for donations and uh
the next day the son ran a headline that
said secret meeting unveiled I told six
million people but I'd had a phone call
that's what the son called it this is
the this is what we're dealing with
um it's interesting looking at Labor's
um policy on green energy right because
it is getting an awful lot of attention
at the minute so this is their green
Prosperity plan 28 billion pounds a year
to fund investment in the green economy
now labor talking about delaying uh
reaching that 28 billion because of the
economic situation do you think that's
the right call first I want to say labor
getting a lot of scrutiny across the
board which is right because they might
form the next government it looks very
likely doesn't it and I think this is
what's causing some of the hysterical
approaches of the right-wing media in
terms of funding so but what's that yeah
look it's an interesting point to me
what's your view on the delayed the
greatest person I think it's not a
problem I think it's a very sensible
thing to do I think obviously we're in
difficult economic circumstances and
there still could be a year or a year
and a half before the election we don't
know how much worse the Tories will make
it before the election so it makes sense
to say we may not go at this completely
in the first year the 28 billion and it
may take a year or two to to reach that
number that's what I heard Rachel Reeves
say and I think it just makes perfect
sense do you think um you know there
might be other people in the shadow
cabinet who look at that funding right
28 billion pounds a year that's a lot a
thing hang on a minute we've got schools
we've got hospitals that could really do
that money why are we spending that
amount on one issue the thing about the
green economy is it's a good investment
for our country so it was education
right so of hospitals that are saving
people's lives yes and fossil fuels are
not
for example for every billion pounds we
invest in fossil fuels versus renewable
energy we can get twice as many jobs
from renewable energy and almost twice
as much GDP growth from that investment
and so a lot of what we need to do to
get to a green economy doesn't require
money at all so would you like to see
labor be a bit more radical on green
issues then uh no I'm happy with where
they are you know it's not for me to say
you know I have my own opinion about
stuff I think you know if they become
the government I think there'll be the
greatest government we've ever seen in
our country and for me that's enough
because I also believe that they
understand the green economy the
environment issues and they'll do the
right things if you look at what the
conservatives are doing they're drilling
for oil and gas in the teeth of a
climate crisis claiming it will lower
energy bills excuse me when it can't
because we allow International markets
to set the price of the fossil fuels we
make here and we pay 10 times more for
our North Sea gas in the energy crisis
than than we used to for no for no good
reason they also claim it will give us
energy security but we can't get new oil
and gas out for four years if we start
today and after 20 years it's all gone
there's no security in something that's
here today gone tomorrow you you are
passionate right about North Sea oil and
gas you can see that there'll be other
people listening to this who think look
if you're wealthy it's easy to be
perfect when it comes to Green energy
right it's easy to drive electric cars
it's easy to make the case for green
levees or energy bills but I guess for
many people who might not be as well off
they think that the priority right now
should be all about the cost of living
it should be helping people feed their
families making sure that people aren't
going to lose their homes is right now
the time to be talking about these
issues I think that it is actually and I
don't support green levees on energy
bills they never should have been there
in the first place they should be paid
for centrally not because that's still
people's money though isn't it you say
pay for centrally that's still people's
money it's not like Magic Money Tree
right people are still paying taxes no
but it's regressive when it's on energy
bills because the the poor Among Us pay
the most proportionally for their energy
with green levees on it shouldn't be
paid for that way
um it's as simple as that and and
in terms of the cost of living crisis
that we Face energy our energy bills are
a big part of that if we transition to
100 green energy and we're at nearly 50
electricity on the grid now already by
the way if we make that complete
transition we can have permanently low
energy bills we can eradicate fuel
poverty we can separate ourselves from
Global fossil fuel markets and be truly
energy independent and and in a great
place the economic benefit to our
country is in excess of 50 billion
pounds a year kept in our economy rather
than shipped out to the rest of the
world uh now I want to just finish by
asking a bit about just stop oil um I
think we might be able to see at the
latest uh protest by then now this was
uh disrupting the ashes you can see
there Johnny birthday physically
carrying off adjustable protester I mean
some people might like the police to
take this approach when they're blocking
roads right I think I think you're right
I've heard that what's your own view I
think it's it's comical I think that you
know much is being made of this in the
news at the moment and actually it was a
few minutes delay to the cricket whereas
the UN estimate that so far the client
okay you've made your major points on
the climate change a lot I just want to
I'm just trying to stick to the Justice
because it's disruption is the point I
want to make a few minutes disruption in
the UN say 4 million people have already
lost their lives and 20 million people
every year are made homeless globally by
the climate crisis that's a few minutes
of cricket
people are losing their homes and their
lives is it is it doing that cause
any good that's the question that's the
killer question though isn't it we don't
know do we right because you know it's a
frequent question and I think the
frequent question but
I think that many people think look
Delane the cricket or
a bit of colorful powder at the snooker
is one thing but the disruption to roads
where people might be trying to use
ambulances to get to hospitals where
people are trying to on zero hours
contracts and they're worried about
making it to their place of work that's
something else well look I was on a
protest around Parliament square a few
weeks ago and they have a fantastic
process for allowing flashing blue
lights through it really works and there
were two while I was there we protested
for about an hour then the police said
look final warning they've got a
protocol for that the protesters
understand when the police say final
warning they get off the streets unless
they want to be arrested four people did
that day it's it's not as bad as it
sounds Central London traffic isn't very
fast anyway and it's a temporary delay
it's here today gone tomorrow the
disruption any sympathy for those
drivers you know the ones who you see
getting out their car pleading yes of
course of course I do but I have
sympathy for the four million people
that have died already the 20 million
displaced they're made homeless every
year already and the more that is to
come for my children and my
grandchildren as well and yours okay
um final question do you have any vices
when it comes to you know the the green
agenda do you like you can't give up
your flight or you you know you have
sausages once a week or something
do I have voices
I like to sit around a an open fire
sometimes Outdoors an outdoor fire
burning some wood but but I don't fly I
don't eat animals
um you know I mean I'm not saying I'm
perfect but do I have advice I like
chips but I don't think that's an
environment advice I'd just like to
that's a very fair advice to have thank
you very much
dietary vices rather than environmental
vices for uh Del Vince there now the
final interview that we've got for you
on the program is something a bit
different because in the last 10 years
we've had five Prime Ministers it's
extraordinary and some of the most
dramatic political times for a
generation and more and that's meant
some pretty extraordinary images of the
PM from Downing Street and Beyond now
Andrew Parsons has captured many of
those images as the official number 10
photographer under David Cameron Theresa
May Boris Johnson Liz truss and he
wasn't for the current resident but he
did take pictures of him as Chancellor
where she seen that now I spoke to
Andrew recently and he brought along
some never before images to show us
I'm quite excited about this interview
because I feel like you've had access to
more prime ministers in a more intimate
way possibly than anyone I've ever
interviewed if you think about it right
yeah no that's right I was the first one
and to go into number 10 as the official
photographer
um and with that I then stayed on to do
four so uh Cameron May Boris and Liz
truss yeah so
there is no one else that's photographed
it or documented it um for that period
of time
um and now it's now it's happened
they've continued on with the uh with
the photographers that are there today
so it's good it's all set up I've had a
lot of access
yeah we're very lucky
uh I could probably count on one hand
when I was asked to leave the room and
it was either one because there was uh
spies that had come in from MI5 or six
or whatever obviously so for obvious
reasons
um two when when they phoned a queen
because we obviously weren't allowed in
there or three or without a private
issue that they wanted to sort out at
the time you know they do have their own
lives that they need to sort out as well
so but I would say definitely on one
hand
um that I was asked to leave and I was
very lucky I mean it was it was a
fantastic opportunity where I had free
reign to go
um in all meetings whether it was the
covid meetings brexit meetings and
towards the end obviously all the
Ukraine meetings that were being held a
majority of the time insecure tight
secure rooms with only very few of us in
there that perhaps would know that was
coming down the track if you had to pick
out like one pinch yourself moment when
you're like I actually can't believe
this is happening
um
yeah it's a question is how it's quite a
lot there's a there's a couple of them
once really the first time I ever
thought that was when Cameron left and
uh Theresa May took over because what
happens is they they're clapped out uh
you do the pictures there's quite a lot
of emotion going around with the staff
because that you know they've been
working for the Prime Minister for so
long so there's a few tears clapping him
out the family are usually with him him
and his children he goes out and then 30
minutes later Theresa May comes in and
they're clapping her in and it's all of
a sudden the Expressions have changed
and it's smiling and like you say it is
pretty brutal and it is from my role I
can't at all get attached to it you just
have to keep on going stay focused and
and then you start again you're in with
the new one the the Theresa May starts
and then the reshuffle starts and it all
happens in one day you start the day
with say David Cameron at eight o'clock
doing his briefing by the evening
um Theresa May is forming a cabinet and
at that point I did think gosh it can't
get any any better in this in the sense
of historic moments but then and the
last year or so has been pretty
turbulent and and every day was
different every day it was just off it
was off diary and things were happening
and flying around and yeah yeah the last
three days but when Boris resigned was
was quite tough yeah it's interesting
hearing you because I kind of feel I
didn't get the same access but out on
Downing Street and you you start off
with one person that elected and then a
couple of hours later so someone else
you're like what's going on it was truly
amazing yeah yeah
um let's let's talk through some of the
moments I want to use some of the photos
that you've taken to do it as well
um here you go
yeah this was a very very old one on
Pancake Day over at his house in West
London where he decided to make us all
pancakes and um purely you quite often
was that it was quite he was quite good
on the stove it would quite often cooked
random things if we were all around
there doing stuff and this was just one
of those moments where he goes right
it's Pancake Day everyone and um and and
away he went sort of thing and the you
told me when we spoke
we're there for the
between the Libya
which I'm kind of I'm kind of fascinated
by how was that so that was 2010 and we
were over in Port Collins house then and
um
it was it was very stop start stop start
stop start oh it's coming close it's
coming close and then there was a lot of
um a lot of pizzas being delivered
ordered in the middle of the night and
stuff like that so they get honest well
as they seem to David Cameron and Nick
Clark uh from from the uh the parts that
I photographed especially in that
Coalition and into the early years of
number 10 then yeah they were they were
very good I remember
um the first time that David Cameron and
Nick clay walked into the cabinet room
together and um and David Cameron did
say to Nick Club we're going to do some
amazing things in this room and they and
they both smiled in an agreement of
um yes we've made it let's make it work
sort of thing and then you went from
David Cameron to Theresa May I mean I
can't really imagine you know a greater
sort of Personality contrast than these
two here she is
um doing her paperwork studious that's
right we were on the flights there
because usually what happens is that um
when the Prime Minister gets in they
then go and tour Scotland Wales and
Northern Ireland and this was one of
those days I remember I think we on our
way to see Nicholas sturgeon from
remember rightly
and uh and Teresa Teresa was lovely to
work for and and in some ways
um you knew where you were um she had a
lovely personality and and was there to
get on with the job rather than worry
about anything else that what we were
doing and things like that so a lot of
stuff with Theresa was at work very
natural
um as opposed to I didn't you know as
opposed to campaigning or doing odd bit
beats I I interviewed Teresa quite a few
times and I've always found her like you
say like very diligent but she she
didn't do small talk at all was she like
that with you behind the scenes or not I
mean every now and again yes not not so
much but every now and again you have to
spend a lot of time with them to have
the small talk if it's if it's small
episodes such as going to Scotland and
back the days are so busy that there's
not much um small talk to be had it's
usually on the foreign trips the Summits
or the
um you know or the various other sort of
leader trips that you'd go and see
um
she she would have a laugh with you she
would have a joke with you there was one
picture I took of her where she's she's
um she's making everyone laugh when
she's leaning on a photocopier um and
she would come out with little
one-liners that would make people laugh
and it would just be that that moment of
surprise that she would give to everyone
because it wasn't expected yeah that
just made her just
um relax and things like that um there's
another classic one she used to do the
morning rounds as you know of at
conference and um she's in the studio
being interviewed for a radio station
and there's a picture of her and
everyone's in stitches and because she's
been she said something very sarky to um
to to the to the interview a journalist
at the time and you had to be on your
card with the others you expected it
with retrievement it was so limited that
when it did happen it was very funny
yeah and then obviously Boris Johnson
yeah Joker uh very different
um person like Hugo he's on a plane this
kind of feels like a classic Boris
Johnson picture yeah that's right that's
when we were um
we were doing a tour off to uh some
military bases I think to go and see the
Ukraine as soldiers being trained by the
Brits and uh they just said you know
that he was tied on obviously and and
and said you know he was offered a seat
at the back to have a look and at which
point he did I think at which point he'd
resigned by then anyway
um and he was just waiting for the
period
um for the for the new one to take over
so it would have been between the July
and September of that year
um but this wasn't him doing a trick he
just went to have a look and you'd go
and join him but he would have no qualms
about you going to join him on on the
back there he wouldn't think it was
unusual like why are you taking a
picture he would actually sort of
understand what we did you know uh I
want to talk about this picture because
this is the moment that Boris Johnson
read Rishi senior Express information
letter that's pretty much in that moment
yeah it's around that secret and this
has never been seen before
um
no not on the not on television I don't
think no no exactly so like this is the
moment where I think this is where he's
starting to say right we can we can
still do this how how did he react
because you know for many people who
thought this is the moment the game's up
right his Chancellor's gone
um well when you're in the room
um you're not really focused too much on
what's being said and what's going on
because you're you're waiting for the
moment to happen but Boris always came
back always always even when he it was
down and out he always came back um one
thing I would say about here man and
David Cameron that when things were
would
um
what seemed to be sort of down and not
and not on his side they sort of
relished on the fight and then it was
gave him more energy if let nothing less
you know and they and they therefore
took that and they sort of as I guess
you could say got the ball and run with
it a lot of the time it's very rare that
I'd see him down and out what were the
times that you did see him down there
um
or I'd have to write those on a postcard
and send them to you I can't remember I
mean is this is this one of them he
looks pretty down and out here no I
think this is just him having a serious
conversation on on his last day in
office yeah and this is the last day in
office he's there with Simon case of
course another person who's been in the
headlines an awful lot recently the head
of the service
um and watching and watching people
getting ready for him to deliver his
speech yeah how was he on this day
um surprisingly well actually I I was
quite surprised I thought there would be
a bit more downbeat about it I mean
don't get me wrong no one was rolling
around laughing but it was business as
usual and this is what we've got to do
and this is where we are at and you know
this is what's happened would it
surprise you if you went for another run
at it then if you came back cool
I don't know I mean I thought what was
quite
tell him the other day was when there
was pictures of him leaving his house in
his old car obviously the dog was was in
the front and he was waving and things
like that and I looked at those pictures
and it reminded me so much of the old
days of when he was mayor and he was out
campaigning and it was like
um one I was surprised he was driving
because usually the cops are driving him
around and stuff
um but that's Boris he wanted to do it
so he's obviously wants to do it but it
just reminded me so much of
of the old days that's interesting just
a picture alone you know the moving
footage of like the photographers and
the film crews around him and but he
wasn't phased by it window down waving
it's it's all it's no problem gang don't
worry we're just on our way out to you
know go out for lunch or whatever and it
it just had that element of yeah made
you think
yeah I paused for a minute thinking oh
interesting it's it's like the old days
and let's see where there we go again
um this is a very different image
obviously this is during covid
yes exactly and um
it was tough um Kobe for everyone
obviously for obvious reasons and um
but inside inside work it was uh news
was filtering through all the time of
what was going on and this would have
been one of those moments where news was
sort of breaking that
um you know whatever trouble was
happening around the country at the time
um
you know and he worked hard had it you
know everyone was in there for long
times periods a day because it was such
a moving moving issue and you obviously
famously
took a lot of the pictures
that were used as evidence in party game
right in the inquiry
I don't know if you can give us any
sense about what was actually going on
in number 10 during that time
well I wasn't partial I was only
um partial to that the one in the
cabinet room so it's not you know I was
asked by the inquiry to hand over those
images of um of the cabinet room is
which is what I did so from the rest of
it
yeah it's difficult you can comment if
you know didn't have the official
photographer there exactly yeah yeah
yeah yeah that makes sense
um definitely
um let's have a little look at I think
we've got Boris Johnson and rishi's CNAC
uh or was she seen that because I'm
quite interested in the relationship
between the two men you obviously saw
them you didn't work for a 69 but you
saw him working for Boris Johnson's
Chancellor did they get on what was it
like yeah yeah they did get on
um and there's pictures of them together
getting on very well indeed you know
um when they're being appointed and at
conferences
um and in meetings etc etc I mean this
one was just taken at conference where
he's preparing to do his conference
speech
um as Chancellor I believe
um and he was um
and and I still do bits and pieces with
him today and on the political front but
um
and he's he's easy easy to photograph uh
that's totally natural picture in fact I
think I'm sort of knelt down by a chair
so it's not like I'm standing up and
he's a parent that I'm does he try and
make himself look taller in pictures
I'm just interested
I've never witnessed um I only do that
because I I tend that's the angles I
tend to like okay very nicely
yeah look I've never seen any evidence
of any props being used to to make
anyone in politics taller okay I tell
you Ruth Davidson did it once for me in
uh in uh in Scotland with her and David
Cameron she stood on a car battery I
think which she uh which is what's sent
me the picture of the other day
then you also
you also hear it um
as she is preparing to resign I think it
is or no that was when the chancellor
resigned oh when she sat consequencing
which must have been a difficult day for
her how was she on that day
um that I mean it's my job is to blend
in and just to just to document what's
in front of in front of me it's not for
me to to judge how they are how they
know there's so much going on they've
got so much
um so many other issues
um as you can see that was like minutes
to spare as you can see by the headline
um on the television there I think she
was due on at 2 30 it's 2 it's 2 29. um
it's you know it's these are tense
moments and you're there to document
these tense moments not there to I'm
definitely not there to judge the
moments because
um with the situations that I've been in
um
I'd spend my life being a judge I had a
judge in the moment you know you you
pretty much blend in you get on with it
it's been extraordinary looking at the
pictures to realize what a roller
coaster period you've done this over and
those pictures of David Cameron feel
like they're from another world and then
you look at stuff like this and you're
like wow this was so intense at the time
yeah do you feel that the experience
that you've had has given you more or
less confidence in the way our country's
run
uh now you're talking politics right
a different thing that's a different
thing um that you know I'm not here to
I'm not here to comment about how the
country is running no it's not run
thanks very much for being on the
program it's a really low interest and
to look at some of the images as well
extraordinary brilliant
bit of a different uh interview there
with Andrew Parsons one of these guys
who really has had a front row seats in
history it's extraordinary to think
about the different Prime Ministers that
he has had that kind of access to we're
going to go straight into the take no
break for us at this morning because
it's been such a busy show so we can
bring in uh Sam coat side Deputy
political editor who's standing by
watching the program uh for us and Sam I
was looking forward to interviewing
Andrew Parsons because if you think
about it it's extraordinary the amount
of access that he's had the things he's
seen over the last few years and I guess
also it's a bit of a reminder about what
an extraordinary period of political
history we've lived through
oh God yes that was absolutely riveting
I I have to confess I was kind of
squinting at the monitor in front of me
to try and get a bigger knife full of
those amazing pictures of moments of
history and hear him talk about it and
uh you are grateful that there is
someone in the room at moments like that
perhaps in in periods in the past there
haven't been people recording that but
Sophie
I I wouldn't I wouldn't be telling the
truth if I didn't say I was also
slightly uncomfortable I think that
there is no question Andrew's fantastic
photographer and a guy with enormous
integrity and you and you saw that
in the role that he's performing he is
not doing it as a journalist he is
employed variously at one point David
Cameron tried to employ him as a civil
servant that role is funded frequently
by the conservative party these are not
fair these are fair uh photographs but
they are not a full representation uh of
the range of scenes that we could have
looked at at those moments
um and I think the important thing to
say the way this works is you will never
get a picture that the principal that
the Prime Minister doesn't want out
there uh if the official photographer is
taking the pictures if you get a
journalist taking the picture a news
photographer somebody from the Press
Association uh who is in the room and
uses their own judgment their editorial
judgment and their editorial selection
as to what pictures uh that you get put
out you get a far bigger range and
moments are caught that you wouldn't
necessarily want if you're prime
minister but that's the price of having
an independent person in the room that
job is not independent the pictures that
are put out are ones that make the
principles look good and so ultimately
the proliferation of people who do roles
like uh the one that Andy does and there
are successes to him in in Downing
Street today they are uh civil servants
now
um it does make me uncomfortable because
very often the pictures that you get on
the front page of newspapers and yes the
pictures that you you get on Sky News
and we we label them quite clearly as
coming from number 10 do not represent
the full selection of images that you
could have had and would have had if you
had a journalist somebody working as a
journalist in the room rather than and
it's a disobedient term but I'm gonna
use it a vanity photographer and this is
the wider point isn't it Sam about the
proliferation as you say different
Outlets that politicians can use
unedited to get their uh views out to
get their information out whether that
is videos that are constructed within
number 10 or number 11 whether that's as
you say photographers who employed uh by
those in governments uh it's definitely
you know a big issue
um let's talk a little bit about the
things stories of the day shall we um
because we have Sue Barclay the health
secretary on and I feel like it's going
to that point now where we're starting
to look very very closely at Rishi sunax
five targets now if you remember these
were the five pledges that he made at
the beginning of the year he was very
very clear this is what he wanted to be
judged on at the time people thought
that it was pretty low-hanging fruit but
I did have to ask the health secretary
whether the government's plans were
working
these were tough targets that he set
himself and rightly said well most
people thought they were easy that they
were low bars well you can now see that
there were tough targets that were set
and it was right that we did so enough
to take way to list the plan is working
we cleared the longest weights that you
awaits we cleared we cleared the longest
ways what the plan set out was the
target the longest ways we cleared the
two-year Waits last summer we cleared
over 90 of the 18 month weights we're
now focused on the 65 week weights
that's the next element of the plan
uh they go that was uh Steve Barkley
they're talking about those uh targets
we can bring Sam back in at this point
it's difficult for them isn't it because
look this is a prime minister who's
pitched himself as someone who makes
things happen who who can do things get
jobs done and if he can't even get the
job done when it comes to his five
targets then he really has got a problem
that's right look there was a very
straightforward plan year one 2023 hit
five targets show that you can deliver
year two 2024 go into the election with
a whole load of new promises and say
look because I can deliver because I've
delivered on this you can trust me to
deliver it on that and none of it is
working out in the way uh that it wants
the
scale of the industrial action is
undoubtedly contributing to the problems
with the waiting lists now I I have this
feeling that back in December January
nobody in number 10 totally appreciated
where this row overpay was going to lead
and so there were unforeseen
consequences of the pay strategy that
the government is now locked in and
determined to double down on not saying
that they'll accept the pay uh review
body but there's a mess this is a little
skip far across all the different bits
of uh of those pledges three of them are
Interlink they're to do with the economy
they're to do with inflation growth and
debt but they're all linked in an
unhelpful way because if there's more
then there might be more inflation so
actually the bank of England is putting
up rates to try and curb growth to bring
down inflation which will mean higher uh
debt than you otherwise would have got
so you've actually got three priorities
of the five that are pulling in opposite
directions uh that's a horrible mess a
horrible mess and there are a lot of
Tories who are utterly miserable when I
saw them this week uh just gone
scratching their heads as to just how
they've ended up in this situation with
the fire test now there is still some
way to go
um people looking at their energy bills
will notice them coming down quite
sharply imminently because of the
reduction in the energy price cap
that'll feed through into inflation
economists still talk about it coming
down quite sharply in the Autumn so
don't write everything off it's
important to say that and we could we
could see some rapid economic
Improvement in terms of inflation but
growth you know 0.1 0.2 percent growth
at the moment potential for a recession
at the turn of the year because of the
need for the bank of England and to
raise interest rates higher than it had
that it thought it was going to have to
because inflation is worse than anybody
predicted all of this is bad and
difficult for richardsonac and going to
rebound on him politically yeah it
certainly is and of course he said on
Sky News that he takes personal
responsibility if those targets aren't
there and we'll talk to Sam about the
other interviews in a moment that
there's just one more
um pieces from this debuggling interview
that I did want to play you and this is
about the funding after how he's going
to fund the NHS Workforce announcement
the reason I want to do to do this is
because this was announced before this
week and I have to say it's a one
question that I haven't seen other
people asking Steve Barkley and I felt
that look if it was Labor I feel that
there would be more scrutiny over how
the policy was funded let's take a
listen
it's 2.4 billion of additional funding
that will be announced by the chancellor
in the usual way at the next fiscal
event so there's additional funding to
the department so I haven't heard any
you know tax Rises or spending cuts so
I'm assuming this sounds like it might
be extra borrowing 100 of GDP that's the
current level of debt interest rates
Rising so the cost of service in
government debt is going up is that
really responsible well it scales up
Sophie so first year obviously you and
have one year of people being trained in
the second year that doubles
the policy of 2.4 billion without saying
how that money was coming from you would
be after them like a rocket
well let's bring some back in I'm not
sure that's an actual phrase after them
like a rocket
um Scott Minato was like you mean a whip
it not a rocket but you get them you get
the right idea
um that's right and but you've got the
politics bang on of course if labor
announced a 2.4 billion pound spending
commitment everyone's going to chase
after them about how it's funded
um and we are just at that point in the
cycle where I think the government just
think they can they can let this slip
through and everyone will be grateful
because it's an announcement of more
funding in an environment where there's
not very much money left
um but I think the big picture on
spending is is actually very striking it
it's very Grim you know in some senses
for public services where the Tories
think they need to be
Tory strategist Tory advisors tell me
that they think that by the time the
next election they need to have quotes
taken health and education off the table
by having promised to spend a huge
amount on it and therefore shut down
Labor's argument that they will fund it
better so that's what where the Tories
need to be it feels like we're miles
away from the tourists being able to do
that on the labor side the number one
priority for the labor party and you see
it in every interview and you saw in
Bridget Phillips interview with you uh
30 minutes ago is to prove that labor of
the party of fiscal responsibility and
the party that will not Fritter away
public money so often refusing to commit
to spending pledges not saying that
there will be much money left uh much
money in the bank for public services
once the election uh is out of the way
if they if they win it so we have a role
reversal of the two main parties it
means that neither uh main party is
doing what you would traditionally
expect them uh to do but it's also
awkward for both of the party leaders
kirstarma and Richie sunak because their
troops see them doing things uh
differently to perhaps how they would
want well let's bring in Bridget
Phillips things I do think the interview
really does illustrate the point that
Sam is making Shadow education secretary
Bridget Phillipson I was asking her
about the childcare offer and The
Breakfast Club offer that the labor
party have
that is normally what happens yes that
is normally what takes place
um what we're seeing at the moment is
far from the normal kind of process so
when you've got a government that has
received these reports won't publish the
report I think it's incredibly
disrespectful we're almost at the end of
the summer term School leaders want to
plan on that basis they don't know what
their budgets are going to be we need a
different kind of relationship it has to
involve respecting teachers for what
they're doing
that was obviously Bridget Phillips and
talking about pay review bodies another
big of the which I guess I does make the
point as well because labor don't want
to commit to too much money as they
would see it for public sector workers
because of those fiscal constraints Sam
was talking about this is a graph I did
want to play about more details on
Labor's plan for childcare
what I was talking about was the
permanent shift that we need to see
where we treat earlier as education and
child care as an integral part of our
education system that is the permanent
shift that I want to see on a scale with
the NHS because what we have in this
country is early as education somewhere
over here not integral to the education
system that is very different from most
of the European countries alongside that
making sure that when we're putting more
money into the system the government did
did respond to what the pressure that
we've been applying and put more money
into the system at the budget that gives
us a better baseline from which to build
a better system that will support
parents
let's bring Sam back in shall we and I
feel like the language on child care
that this is going to be reform like the
creation of the NHS is not really
matched when you look at the policy from
labor
no
um I've sat through a lot of interviews
that you have done with labor front
bench politicians Sophie and just and
it's not you it's them just so much of
the content uh just just falls through
your fingers as they Dodge the kind of
hard facts the hard facts that Bridget
Phillips and willing to talk about are
is The brexit Breakfast Club commitment
that there will be access to a breakfast
club for every kid uh from nine months
to 11 years old now maybe this week
maybe kirst will announce something
bigger on child care of course Jeremy
Hunt uh the conservative Chancellor uh
in the last budget put a lot of money
into Child Care labor have been kind of
boxing and constantly and working out
what their updated offer is so so maybe
Bridget Phillips just didn't want to
steal uh kirst Armor's Thunder
um but but there is often a frustration
at just how little specific there is to
clean cling on to after an interview
like this labor labor had their own idea
of what they were going to do in this
interview they were going to announce
the two-year the plan to give a sort of
one-off bonus to new teachers after two
years that's the that's the new fact
that they've got funded out of their
plan to uh to raise taxes on private
schools that's the Nugget that we were
allowed to know but but yet on the much
bigger question we we got neither the
plan nor the principles because they
don't think the rhetoric were actually
principles it was just kind of rhetoric
I didn't really know where it left me
clear in that interview about at all
where they are when it comes to teachers
pay at one point she said that the 6.5
that we're expecting the pay review body
to recommend would be a good starting
point for negotiation and I honestly
wasn't clear if she meant it was a good
starting point and they'd be preferred
to go higher as the teacher unions want
as Mary bastard said she hoped or if
they meant that would be the teaching
Union's starting point and they would
have to try and Wilt them down
neither did I I mean I kind of felt I
should have felt for Mary bastard uh who
he was who was who was making that point
but but it comes back to this thing what
do labor want you to notice of that
interview they want you to notice that
they are not writing blank checks
um they know and you know and I know
that come the time of the next election
the conservative party are going to run
an argument that labor will bankrupt the
economy if they get into power and labor
is doing everything it can to try and
insulate themselves as best they can
from that charge by looking tough so
they're not signing up to even pay
review bodies pay you believe that they
uh uh kind of you know promise to adhere
to the recommendations of in the past
and so they sort of want you to hear
that they're being tough but then they
add in this little Rider which is but
remember when we were last in government
we did give teachers and doctors a lot
more money but we're not going to
promise that now but remember what we
did last time and they're hoping that
the public kind of join the dots without
the make taking actually a formal
promise of more money at a time where
there's almost money no money left so
again you know it's triangulation it's
an attempt to give everybody a little
bit of what they want to hear but the
biggest message is that they want people
to hear is no you can't automatically
expect to get big lump sums in order to
try and mix that core argument on the
economy that the Tories will make about
the labor party over the course of the
next year
um the final thing that I just want to
ask you about is the reflection I guess
on the interview with Mary balsted the
head of the National Education Union I
mean she was pretty clear wasn't she
that these strikes are continuing that
they're unhappy with the payoffer from
the government and then of course with
Steve Barkley as well talk about Junior
doctors there is no end in strike and in
sight that's a very uh good forging slip
there and strike
um for that one either I mean just how
difficult is the situation with these
industrial disputes
I mean he's I really think it's it it is
incredibly difficult because the NHS
disputes are having a direct effect on
people
um getting treatment and on waiting
lists and on the performance of the NHS
and on morale in the NHS and patience
ability uh to get very urgent uh help so
uh when it comes to schools every time a
school shuts down uh it's not just the
teachers on strike but parents very
often kept at home uh not able to do
their job a real hit on the economy and
yet you know that even though the
government is announcing an NHS
Workforce plan dealing with the strike
you know sorting out the issue on pay is
deemed not part of that because they
don't want to pay more because it might
fuel inflation even though the link
between inflation uh and public sector
pay is is indirect it needs to be sorted
it's difficult it I find it baffling
that it's not and it really hurts
um really good to talk as always Sam
thank hates that uh talking from his
South London
um office
good to see you on this morning's safe
Ridge on Sunday the podcast will follow
around lunchtime so do check that one
out see you next week